[Music]
what's one thing that you would say to
your ex ex is that you've loved before
you'll never find anyone better
something like this right or look at me
now my letters are my most secret
possessions I write them when I have a
crush so intense I don't know what else
to do
there are five total make that six if
you're counting actress Lana condors
real-life childhood crush Zac Efron what
a man oh my god like I would have got
like j14 and Tiger Beat those like like
teen magazines that have put him all
over the place he's he's my one true
love oh I still have phone mr. day
puttin it out there put it out
from high school musical heartthrob
solana dishing on her high school days
is there anything that you remember from
your high school years that would be
surprising to know about you or were you
anything like Laura Jean like super shy
in high school I was a lot more like
larger than I am now I think I it's I
think I'm pretty outgoing but that's a
learned trait but in high school I was a
lot more I think reserved ya know I went
to an all-girls school oh wow so I what
was that like yeah I I mean I ain't
quite enjoyed doing to all the boys one
for cuz I felt like it got the actual
co-ed experience so I went to all-girls
school now that was fun
but I love not hot like I love just
putting on a uniform and living my life
but I also like to flirt with guys so I
didn't get to do that in high school
look I got a little bit of that fix in
this yeah tell me how in sync did you
feel with your character was there any
area that where art imitated life for
you absolutely I think I live in my own
world and I think Laura G and she lives
in her own world she you know she's kind
of blissfully unaware of you think or
what's going on around her but I think
that's like a coping you know mechanism
and whatnot but yeah I hope I live in a
fantasy world myself so being able to
play such a dreamy character was like oh
yeah I could do that I could do that
what if we let people think that we were
actually together let's do this what is
one thing that you hope fans and viewers
take away from this film when it comes
to dating and treating people and love
tell people how you feel because life's
too short
don't be afraid to love and then keep
loving and keep loving and doing more
loving because we need that in the world
right now so I hope you I hope fans take
away that love keep on doing it
love hard be vulnerable yes love art
love hard be vulnerable
[Music]
[Applause]